but that's another thing right it's like
I think the the first time that we saw
like actual human evolution was when
Aristotle was just like philosophy is a
thing now yeah right yeah because it's
before because I wanna because I always
found that weird
that like I can't like has it didn't
really take that long for Humanity for
someone to be like
I'm thinking about it okay so so why
okay okay okay okay
the weirder again it's like one day
someone was like I'm thinking about
something
no why no this is so short-sighted to
think that there's there's always been
people who have thought about [ __ ]
before that yeah we were really [ __ ]
bad we were like should we keep a record
of stuff no and then Who's Gonna Keep
the records we were having trouble just
we'll just tell it to our team we were
having too many wars we were killing
each other all the time and Woody when
you take over a place are you gonna keep
their [ __ ] thoughts on a piece of
paper [ __ ] that [ __ ] I'm burning that
[ __ ] [ __ ] down he was dumb as
[ __ ] I killed him right I don't want to
know what he thought I wanted these
people thought so we were just too busy
trying to get by no and it's not what
we're doing today
Aristotle we're just doing that's why no
one cares about climate change because
we're like the damn gas prices are
making my survival harder it's all a
full circle we all keep [ __ ]
ourselves and the people in charge keep
[ __ ] us that's what I'm saying I just
love how you make it sound like
Aristotle invented thinking yeah
he did not he invented he he invented
the science of culture no he's the only
one that we remember and that we
bothered to keep his [ __ ] books
around everyone else we wiped from do
you know how many like civilizations
that Britain probably [ __ ] raided and
just destroyed all that well then you're
suggesting that before Aristotle there
was no writing no there was but we just
didn't keep it right we burned it or got
rid of it or let it go to waste but then
wouldn't you think that if someone
before Aristotle had come up with the
idea of things
okay okay so make um let's make
something up I'm not sure let's do it
let's do a little let's do a little
thing uh let's say you're the kingdom of
uh what's your kingdom called uh Deez
Nuts Kingdom of Deez Nuts right you have
uh what's your philosopher called uh
[ __ ] Tits McGee so tits McGee's is
made basically like these amazing books
that the Deez Nuts Empire just reveres
yes well turns out they spent a little
too much time thinking and not raising
their army and Chad gone over here comes
and destroys the kingdom of Deez Nuts
right and he thinks that your race is
just inferior because you couldn't beat
him in battle so let's destroy all your
words stuff because we don't care about
what you say and we'll take the fun
little Bridges you built and the little
toys you built okay then here's the
thinking we don't want that so we
destroyed that because we're gonna our
own guys are smarter because we won if
you guys were smart they would have
thought about it okay then if that's the
case then why did we keep the books from
the Greeks
well I mean it was it was closer to our
time period where preservation of
information mattered more right and
culture started mattering more right
stuff like that started to become more
yeah but it's not like it's not like
when the Greece popped off suddenly
we're all like don't burn the books
everyone no no no no no but it's like
it's like it was a gradual thing I mean
there's a number of factors to why that
period and other periods like the Roman
stuff is so well documented right and
it's because a lot of the times as well
when and when these places would get
taken over other the other places taking
them over or whenever the empire fell or
whatever they might also have a respect
for what they've the stuff that they've
also shared or come up with right no I
get that but like if I wasn't specific I
feel like this is wrong oh no it's
absolutely wrong I have no information
on this this is just like this is what
I'm imagining for like a thousand of
years we were terrible at keeping any
documents about anything right no but I
believe like
I don't believe Aristotle I don't even
know if he was technically this that's
why I'm saying there's no idea he was
the first I don't believe he was the
first one I believe he might have been
the first one to actually put a name to
it he was the only one smart enough to
be like I'm thinking really hard I
should probably make I should probably
put this under a word so everyone can
know what I'm doing right now well
they're just thinking there's other you
know other sects of life that are very
closely tied
he's the world's first five what
religion is just philosophy just in a
nice package in like a DLC like think
about it like the philosophy of like
it's like a religion and that whole
thing is it's like a it's like a whole
package I mean that's a whole lot you
know what I mean yeah what I'm saying is
that like it's just it's just a way of
life in a way of agreeing to how you
think it is like so saying that he's the
first one is just completely wrong but
then but then I always wonder right
taking that taking that logic of like
you know uh say for example when The
Barbarians took over the Romans all
right why was it then that the all the
Roman stuff is so much more well but
reserved then say all the stuff before
it even though the barbarians probably
didn't give a [ __ ] about the one I'm not
a historian so I can't tell you that
yeah stories please let us know because
I always wondered that I'm sure there's
because you know what was the turning
point where people were like maybe we
should start respecting other cultures
to the point where we preserve their
stuff I think I think it goes beyond
that it's like you you get to a point in
society where you realize oh being smart
about sorry being powerful having a
powerful Army that maybe that may be
more to life than just taking over
people you know there may be more to
life otherwise half the things in
society wouldn't matter exactly but what
was the Turning Point that's what I want
to know what was the Turning Point yeah
what was the turning point between let's
burn everything and everyone that
they've ever loved so that we can
pretend that it never existed no no no
it just you know at different times in
the Life in history people value
different things right at one point they
valued you know they maybe they realized
oh we could also sell this stuff oh we
could do stuff with this instead of just
destroying it all and pillaging and all
that stuff yes yes yes of course of
course yeah yes yes I mean like if like
I don't think we should
ah discredit not even discredit but play
Down how important philosophy very much
philosophy has come to like shape just
how we how we live and everything like
that because you're looking like you
look at like the such different
mentalities and way of thinking between
let's say like the west and like the
East you know and you see a lot of a lot
of people who are in Asia was very much
um their mentality is very much based
from that Chinese philosopher who I
forget the name of now each one
Confucius Confucius Confucius right that
is it's just like it's gone so far back
that it's literally steeped in society
and like yeah the mentality
that's also another problem is that yeah
with Aristotle Socrates Socrates yeah
sorry I got that completely wrong so
replace or every Aristotle
yeah sorry I'm not I just get enough to
know who yeah
so
also as well another thing has to be
taken into account is that our history
and our understanding of it is very
English Central centralized yes we don't
know
um we're not we don't educate about like
Asian history or African history as much
as we should so our view of the world
inherently as well already is already
biased as [ __ ] well we're like yeah the
Greeks man there's [ __ ] guys it's
another the dudes who they know what
they're talking about oh there's other
people uh trying to [ __ ] them they don't
know what's going on you know what I
mean
but you know it's like a it's a very
close proximity and it's a history that
a lot of people have subscribed to for a
lot of time so we're biased as [ __ ] yeah
course this is hard as [ __ ] because just
this is like too much stuff it's just
too much for any one person to keep
track of everything and have a good
globally minded view on everything so
yeah that's why we haven't evolved far
enough for that yes no we're never going
to we're not brain is already running in
like 110 percent you never know what do
you mean again we might just be the
Neanderthal in the chain of humans we
don't know that well Japan has barely
figured out web design I'm not getting I
am not holding up any hopes for our
[ __ ] brain capacity to evolve oh yeah
yeah it's gonna take millions of years
and I think we'll we're going to invent
something that I can think better than
us
that's computers we've already invented
something that can think better than
that that's all right
we're gonna be owned by Jeff Asos
Jeff Bezos is going to be like Angeles
in the sky it's just like a big face
that just overlooks the Earth yeah
exactly yeah I mean it's complicated
yeah yeah of course that's the episode
it's complicated but that's why I like
these kinds of discussions because it's
just like a never-ending like list of
what ifs that let's be real it's like no
one's ever gonna [ __ ] know the answer
it's like it's like it's like three guys
in an old person home trying to remember
what they all had for breakfast and not
none of them actually no we're just
theorizing
four days ago so [ __ ] you it don't you
know like I feel like uh you didn't even
come into this all her folks are in four
days
what do you mean you missed out Dave you
weren't even here four days ago
holy [ __ ] I have a lot of strong
opinions for being wrong
what do you mean
this many episodes to figure that out
I'm just saying I'm fully aware of that
I I know his brain's developed enough to
tell us at least at least you
acknowledge that at least if you tell me
some facts I'll believe you yeah
could you give me some information
you're like this is what some dude said
online who's very knowledgeable I'm like
all right right I'll just trust the
sauce sometimes sometimes you just like
this is the problem though is that when
when you're like do you believe Socrates
invented velocity or no he didn't invent
philosophy it literally says he invented
philosophy before Socrates there was no
concept of philosophy that we believe
that we know of but like but like I
don't I don't think that he invented
like documented and organized it made it
appealing yes yes I agree I don't think
Socrates was the first person to then
say think really hard I tried a shape
don't [ __ ] come at me and tell me
that nobody else thought about some of
the stuff
like was he the first person to let's
say make it marketable
what a simple trick people would come to
listen to Socrates talk yes right this
is this is no different than [ __ ]
fortune tellers back in the day this is
like another branch of just talking
talking [ __ ] and trying to make people
believe it but this one just happened to
be actually are you saying
no no but like it's in my mind it's like
the same realm of stuff where it began
from right it's like the business of
trying to to talk to people and preach
stuff for money and and trying to do
that yes yes well like it's like I guess
what we do I guess we're getting into it
really philosophical discussion of how
do you even Define philosophy oh God
we're doing it again
right now we have things how do you
define we are thinking about